this video is sponsored by ridgewallet
last week i tackled the first few films
of one piece against my will and i
thought by and large they were pretty
good some not so much but you know we're
getting more hits than misses so how was
this we go pain painful scary
huh
i'm i'm sorry
this week i'm discussing movies 5 7 and
10 but more importantly i'll be
discussing and giving my first
impressions on movie six from one of my
favorite directors in japan and the
wider world memorial hosoda this was a
film that well it's hard to put it
simply but i will try because i'm
totally not mark and these are my first
impressions of thoughts on and review
for the stunningly beautiful tragic and
horrifying one piece movies five
six
seven
and ten
first up one piece the cursed holy sword
one piece the cursed holy sword is a
2004 film produced and distributed by
toei animation with a runtime that's
actually 95 minutes but feels like 905
minutes i didn't like this movie of all
the films in this series thus far it
bored me the most however with that said
there are aspects specifically towards
the beginning and the ending that i did
like so let's take a closer look the
first scene is short and effectively
introduces us to the main antagonists
future trunks and the titular cursed
holy sword which seems to primarily heal
the wielder as well as severely harsh
their chill once again nami is in search
of treasure on a random tropical island
while luffy is getting fat on food these
films seem to really enjoy those tropes
and i say that because they use them a
lot i understand that it's a useful way
of getting the plot to move forward but
gee golly gosh if it doesn't feel like
i've seen this setup a million times at
this point they even have the same
marines chasing them from movie four so
at least there's some internal
consistency there i guess in the
previous movie i complimented the story
from making use of robin's backstory in
an interesting and believable way to
shed light on the exposition that's
crucial to the story they tried to do
that here but it's more in your face
exposition with robin vomiting up all of
what we need to know in about a minute
how did she learn this some good
old-fashioned book learning i guess
because i guess robin's character is
that she likes books
well it looks like zoro observed
something he goes to confront them when
the rest of the crew are forced to flee
the harbor due to the navy there's this
set piece that happens and i'm not sure
if i like it here nami is the navigator
right she's needed because she
understands how the ship moves and
maneuvers in relation to the weather
better than pretty much anyone arguably
in the whole one-piece universe yet
luffy is the one that surprises nami by
instructing the ship to keep going
straight because in doing so it flies
this is the same man that thought
jumping into a barrel was an effective
mode of transport and to make matters
worse the story injects some random
chance and luck into the equation by
having the ship land on the back of an
animal and bounce which doesn't really
make sense onto another body of water
they didn't know was there what happens
when a movie is made completely driven
by cocaine okay so i guess the entire
chase sequence there was only to split
up the crew and start their search for
zorro who by the way seems to be all
pally pally with future trunks now
there's a lot of weird stuff happening
on this island between zoro teaming up
with this dude the marines helping him
and a weird village with purple dragon
balls luffy after having splintered all
from the main group alongside ustop
begins fighting future trunks there's
some fun animation but overall i'm not
really feeling this villain he doesn't
really have any motivation for me to
care about and i have no idea what he's
actually like which doesn't help matters
luffy ultimately loses and then we get a
nice gag with usopp jumping off the
cliff luffy fell off of after him it's
probably my favorite part of this film
so far though once he does land he
discovers a hole and falls through it
now i've been avoiding this but one
aspect i found very little interest in
were the village scenes these make up a
decent chunk of time spent in this movie
getting to know the villagers the
blue-haired lady and the warriors of the
village themselves and while i can
appreciate a portion of the runtime
being dedicated to establishing new
characters and fleshing them out the
vast majority are so vapid and
relentlessly lifeless it only serves to
create a portion of the film that i have
zero interest in and really this is a
problem that plagues the entire story i
do not care about future trunks and his
cursed sword you can call it a cursed
sword all you want it doesn't make it
automatically cool okay maybe a little
bit but that's beside the point this
sword by and large sucks i do not care
about blue haired lady or her village of
people i swear if it got any more
exciting in that village a funeral might
break out we're given flashbacks
recantings of legends further insight
into the circumstances that have
befallen herself in the character of
future trunks but i just can't bring
myself to care primarily the thing that
we care about in these films are the
straw hat crew and their safety and so
much of the film sees them sharing the
screen with these characters instead of
interacting with each other for me the
most interesting scenes thus far have
been the comedic sequences following
luffy and usop as they journey back to
the main group which in a very obvious
way only serves the purpose of delaying
luffy's return to the action to end it
which means my favorite portion of the
second act comes from a delay sequence
in the story and that's sort of a
problem but i suppose it's unfair to
label those scenes as just a lace
they're also incredibly convenient too
because luffy happens to find the purple
balls which were taken from the village
might i add completely by chance and
decided to pick them up and bring them
back to the rest of the group anyways
let's wrap this up they gotta bring the
purple dragon balls to these temples for
protection or something zoro turns on
his captors and starts slicy slicey
sword manning them this is effectively
the portion where all the significant
action the film takes place zoro loses
his initial jewel luffy takes over and
does his rubber man hokey pokey wham bam
thank you ma'am on future trunks but oh
no he turns into sword broly and man
that moon is really big and red and man
those temples are falling down
thankfully however zoro returns and asks
luffy to step aside such that he can
finish what he started and to be frank
this sequence is appropriately framed
and feels totally right to me unlike the
rest of this movie it's easily its
strongest part there's some really great
shots with a nice bit of conflict
nestled into zoro's head if i was to
only look at this third act in isolation
i'd be very interested to look at the
rest of the film assuming it would be
just as good unfortunately the rest of
it at least to me felt lifeless and at
the worst of times boring from a visual
front it's consistent and if you're a
big fan of the series there's some cute
character moments in here for zorro
towards the beginning and end for you to
enjoy in addition to the comedic
material covering usop's escapades with
luffy the tunnels it might be worth
checking out but for me i can say i'll
personally be returning to this one next
up is movie six one piece baron omasuri
and the secret island one piece baron
omasuri and the secret island is a 2005
film of sorrow pain and nightmare fuel
that kept me up long into the night that
i watched it it was produced and
distributed by despite the strikingly
different visual approach toei animation
it's got a runtime of about 92 minutes
of lighthearted fun followed immediately
after by night terrors i would not be
surprised if kids discovered new phobias
while watching this film but with that
said i'm a well-adjusted adult screw
those kids this movie was awesome for
those of you that don't know i'm a
massive fan of amoro hosoda and one of
my favorite movies is the girl that left
through time he has a list of massive
titles to his name and when i heard that
he did a one-piece film i was more than
a little interested to see this thing in
motion and boy
does this one move from a visual
standpoint i found this film
incorporated more personality expression
and emotion into a single frame or
action sequence than perhaps any shown
in movie i've ever seen in my life this
film is capital g gorgeous this film
hits different and that's primarily
because of the minimalist character
designs and thin line work indicative of
asura's work his style is so distinct
you can pause it at any given moment
until it's in a soda film just through
expressions line work and framing visual
impact is one thing script writing is
another and this film is firing on all
cylinders delivering in all of these
departments but let's ignore the sudden
shift to pain and misery in the second
half just for a moment the first half is
so much fun and that fact is leveraged
later to create the biggest shock i've
had since i watched water shift down as
a kid this film felt super short
especially in direct comparison to the
last film there wasn't a moment during
this where i myself wasn't completely
and totally invested in what was going
on on screen i was either laughing
snickering or crying but more on that
later the first half of this script
focuses heavily on natural and quick
exposition to get us into the story
centered specifically around
lighthearted banter character
introductions and a premise setup that i
found to be fantastic and interesting
most of the expository heavy lifting was
taken care of in the first eight minutes
if you believe that essentially the crew
want to go onto this pirate island for
rest relaxation and fun but once they
arrive they discover that everything is
not as it seems confronted by a
so-called baron with this cute little
flower on his shoulder and all of his
followers because of this the straw hats
find themselves caught up in this game
for survival if they win this fishing
game they get the treatment they wanted
but if they don't win then something
nebulously bad happens now naturally
everyone except bluffy doesn't want to
do this and the crew's already
infectious dynamic is accentuated by
some absolutely fantastic character
animation like once us learns that this
game requires him to catch a goldfish in
a small net he suddenly jumps to the
opportunity to save the day acting like
the best gold fisherman in all the land
which honestly was so damn funny helped
enormously by the animation itself and
the entire first half is like that and
what's more is i think this scene offers
me a chance to explore with you all why
this film's pacing feels so snappy and
entertaining almost every scene serves
more than one single purpose unlike
prior films where scenes were used to
shout exposition at the audience this
one with usop on top of delivering
comedy also introduces us to the powers
and strengths of the crew as they cycle
through different attacks and strategies
to get the giant goldfish into the
bucket we get progression for the story
towards the current goal which is at the
moment to get their reward we also get
the reaction from the baron once the
straw hats finally get the victory and
that's not even to make mention of the
complex character dynamics at play
throughout this scene that make it as
enjoyable and fun as it is ending the
scene in a brilliant way with a tracking
shot following chopper having been
knocked into the ocean the camera holds
on him just long enough for us to think
in our head is anyone coming and then it
takes even longer and would you know it
the first person down there after him
was luffy the guy who can swim this is a
man that literally would not hesitate to
throw his life away for his crew the
official canon has used this type of
scene as a joke several times over and
is often used for comedic effect but
this movie treats that scenario with
real weight it emphasizes luffy's love
for his crew his family and that's
precisely the psychological burden this
movie explores think of this small scene
as a prelude but yeah that's just one
example of a scene that will enhance
everything coming afterwards the straw
hats themselves in this film are all
perfectly characterized but the
antagonists are honestly just as quirky
and fun in the first contest with the
goldfish we were introduced to this
overconfident overweight guy named
muchigoro but the second contest
features four old short people dressed
in frog costumes there's also a head
chef and a dj but no matter who it is
all of the baron's followers seem to
have this plant on top of their heads
it's cute so cute in fact i bet nothing
horrific or existential could possibly
come out of it all of the individual
challenges are great in their own ways
too the second one advertised as a
simple ring tass event turns into a
high-speed gondola race where the goal
is to restrain their opponents in the
life rings this setup provides way more
action than the prior featuring the
bickering and comedic goals from zorro
and sanji teaming up and the cowardly
duo of usop and nami and these teams are
honestly perfect for hijinks chef's kiss
it was so easy to get sucked into the
ebb and flow of the action that once
usual accidentally flew off and left
nami alone to fend for herself i
completely forgot about him until he
came back in with the clutch save and on
its face this really isn't anything new
movies are inherently like magic tricks
a lot of them follow the same steps the
same formula for creating tension and
drama if you see the same trick or set
up multiple times it loses its luster
this film uses perfect characterization
as its sleight of hand however so
forgetting about usopp is just a
testament to how invested i was in zorro
and sanji's heightened conflict now the
ring toss event isn't the only thing
happening during this portion of the
movie also i've spoken at length before
about how the second act in the
three-act structure can be somewhat
tiresome lord knows i found the future
trunks movie to be boring as sin but
this really strong and exciting gondola
ring toss competition with nami usab
zoro and sanji is juxtaposed perfectly
with a camera more subdued set of scenes
the crew members not participating in
the ring toss luffy chopper and robin
are left to their own devices and each
of them explore the rest of the
surrounding area robin decides to
inquire about the flower on the shoulder
of the baron while she attempts to
extract information from muchigoro both
chopper and luffy become acquainted with
other folks that have come into conflict
with the baron in the past since these
scenes aren't as action-packed some
younger viewers might lose interest but
i personally was fascinated by these
building tensions there's been an
underlying uneasiness within this island
from the get-go and i want to know the
island's secrets don't think i don't i
definitely didn't this movie scared me a
lot we learned three crucial facts in
each of these scenes one the baron's
followers aren't the only people on this
island luffy meets a short mustachioed
man and chopper meets a small family by
way of their skittish father he has
three children with him and the youngest
ends up being the most important in this
film secondly something bad is happening
luffy is told that the baron is in fact
behind it and thirdly the source of the
trouble is some kind of flower i know
not threatening i get it but wait thanks
to muchi goto robin learns the name of
this plant as the lily carnation and
this becomes important later all of
these scenes are also shot to reinforce
the tone of their respective
interactions and encounters robbins is
casual and intimate so there's a lot of
standard medium to close shots
incorporating a significant amount of
visual flair through the subtle and fun
character acting chopper is continually
framed with obstructed long shots he's
pictured small in the vast empty
environments to communicate how isolated
he is and how oddly quiet the town is
and luffy is very clearly an abstract
comedy take on the chase sequence
complete with a benny hill reference but
once the chase reaches its conclusion we
get a very simple standoff with another
humorous conclusion once all of these
complete we begin approaching the
midpoint turn in the narrative and as
you would expect we get it in the middle
of the second act the purpose of this
technique is to suddenly shake things up
and put the main cast in the back foot
as they head into the second half of the
film and ultimately towards the third
act or climax and conclusion these are
usually swerves that tried to take the
audience by surprise some are more
effective than others and usually they
work well enough but as i'm watching
sanji show off in front of this iron
chef and while nami was talking with
mochigoro i was greeted by a midpoint
turn that shook me to my very core in
her conversation the nami learns that he
his crew
and his captain were on a similar level
to goldie roger but the dialogue slows
to a crawl when he starts talking about
roger in the present tense citing that
he only saw him recently and that's
about when a creepy look begins to fall
across his face before mentioning the
big storm immediately the camera
switches to robin's point of view as she
discovers the flower growing on the
island the flowers she learned about
from muchigoro and as the candles
flicker and the scenes switch in a
frantic fashion from various characters
it lands on nami and moochigoro's
conversation
welcome to the horror portion of the
film and it's bloody awesome in a sort
of existential and hopeless way that
still has left me a little empty inside
so after this the crew grows concerned
and things begin getting a little more
serious chopper has been missing for
quite some time now and usopp and robin
are nowhere to be found this is when
sanji reminds luffy that this was all
his idea in the first place that he was
the one who decided to participate in
these challenges on behalf of everybody
again this is nothing really new to the
series the crew faced pam all the time
at these situations luffy recklessly
barrels into but rarely do we see them
get irrationally angry at him here it's
not for comedy there's weight to it
which i love it's taking an element that
existed in the manga and twisting it
into something more serious on the flip
side with his crew feeling tired or in
the worst case scenario turned into a
dried husk like muchigoro the baron
starts to announce the final trial luffy
at this moment is still distraught at
the thought that he might be responsible
for his greatest fear to come to pass
that being his friend's demise and this
is when he gets serious places his hat
on his head and begins going toe to toe
with the baron but he clearly can't
stand up to him one-on-one and just as
he's about to die he gets pulled down
into one of the tunnels by the gentleman
he met earlier and while the rest of his
crew gets taken out most interestingly
the little green-haired water imp gets
taken out by zorro and something
interesting happens
this is the first scene where we see the
baron's psychosis on full display and
what this illusion he's been living in
has been created for now i will
acknowledge that there is an element to
this film where i can see some people
taking issue with and that is the fact a
major component that creates the dire
circumstances at the end is that the
majority of the crew had a falling out
with other individual members and while
it isn't a common occurrence to see
these characters behave like this it
didn't really bother me in the slightest
i've been consistently viewing the straw
hats as a family unit for some time now
and one almost sure-fire defining
feature of a family is that they are
prone to fighting and disagreement the
way nami and usa fall out in this film
is definitely something you've seen from
a dysfunctional family and the straw
hats definitely fit that billing the
arguments they experienced here always
felt like superficial spats that
otherwise would have ironed themselves
out in a matter of hours had the
situation been better but it wasn't
better it just so happens that this
entire island is going to hell and luffy
literally in the island's underbelly
gets a firsthand look at the stark
reality he's facing in a heart-to-heart
revelation brief lets luffy know that he
has lost his own crew too the toothbrush
mustache pirates all to the demonic
flower at the heart of this island when
he reveals this information he doesn't
say that his crewmates died he says that
he's alone fear and sudden realization
drains luffy's face almost instantly and
with that we quickly cut from the
beginning of an explanation to the exact
same scenario playing out right now with
chopper the imagery is equal parts stark
and horrific everything is black white
and muted the carnation's presence is
equal parts staggering and haunting as
it slowly begins digesting its prey the
interesting thing here is that the
adults are resigned to the outcome baron
omatsuri relishes in the abject terror
while papa walks away chopper on the
other hand is 15 years old in this scene
he fights valiantly against overwhelming
odds the one who tries to save him first
is daisy the youngest of papa's three
children and that's when you realize
that those that are too young to know
any better but do not know the pain of
loss they are the ones that fight the
hardest papa does eventually turn around
to fight but he doesn't save chopper he
pulls daisy and the rest of his family
away he's there for them he doesn't have
the fortitude to stick his neck out for
someone he doesn't know because the one
thing that he can't afford to lose right
now is his own family and after chopper
is gone he's reprimanded by that same
family for doing so in this film we have
three separate captains all dealing with
the challenges of life and death the
baron lost his crew and ripped his soul
in half he now clings on to the memory
of his fallen comrades and wishes to
inflict that same pain unto others brief
the mustache man lost his crew as well
but instead of giving up and resigning
himself to his fate he stays and fights
yes he's alone but the memory of his
comrades lives on in his struggle for
survival and lastly the father papa is a
coward he didn't even compete in the
challenges and ran away at the first
hint of danger he's too scared to act
because he knows he'll lose what he
values most ironically the very family
he wants to protect is the thing that's
holding him back from true courage which
brings us finally to luffy who is
now
alone he's caught right in the middle of
all three characters current plight his
crew is still alive and they need his
help the outcome of the next half hour
will determine whether or not he becomes
one of the three other captains or
learns from their mistake to chart his
own path it's no accident he winds up
with brief in the tunnels the only one
on the island left with the requisite
backbone to stand up to the baron is
also the one who gives luffy purpose and
motivation he instantly leaps into
action setting off a dramatic showdown
with the baron but unfortunately it's
too late one by one each of his crew
members are taken each new victim
results in an arrow in one of luffy's
limbs helplessly pinning him against a
rock will you fight with only your left
leg the baron asks and luffy responds by
raising his left leg the weight of this
scene is honestly smothering the mere
thought of losing his oldest and most
loyal crewmate in zorro sends him into a
frenzy he launches his head towards the
flower exposing his neck in the process
to the barons arrows blood flies and it
looks like he's struck in the head the
fatal blow however was missed he caught
an arrow with his teeth but the next
moments bring us nothing but pain and
tragedy a close-up of luffy's enraged
face is cross-cut with zorro melting
into the flower rage turns to disbelief
and finally grief as the straw hat
captain slams lifelessly back to the
rocks below there is no music no swell
of evil cords the baron simply walks
forward and speaks harsh truths luffy is
now alone on the ground line the rest of
the barons followers come back to life
they literally feed on the death and
misery of others only then does the
baron twist the knife taunting luffy
while the flower on his shoulder
literally chews on his crew and while it
does so he offers him a quick relief
death
growing up i always appreciated the hero
of any story that could stand up to
anything that when faced by overwhelming
odds in the face of absolute destruction
when given two options does the
impossible and creates his own option
characters like goku iron man spider-man
and countless others in anime and
fiction all had this in common and i
think there's tremendous utility in that
sort of hope for young people but i dare
say that this particular film more so
than any other i've seen in this genre
is better suited for adults the themes
in it are harsh and cruel almost
unreasonably so and while the
circumstances are not realistic the pain
luffy is facing in it is easy to
empathize with because of what's
transpired i can appreciate at this
moment in time luffy feels like he has
nothing left to fight for having
traversed impossible odds in the face of
absolute evil and cruelty in the east
blue and the grand line he finally found
himself in a circumstance where he
couldn't find a solution
okay so to say that this moment took me
by surprise would be an understatement
of the highest order as a massive fan of
what's transpired at the shabbat
archipelago in the manga for a scene
like this in this film to exist in such
a powerful fashion had me not only
invested but i was very much tearing up
this film succeeds on many different
levels but for me the most successful
aspect of it was how it pulled me in
gave me hope and then ripped it away one
character at a time before leaving the
symbol of hope in the series a hollow
husk of a human being defeated and
crushed by the weight of his
circumstances this created the perfect
time in the film for the writer to
deliver this swerve this last minute
save that made me audibly gasp as it
happened with this moment made even more
potent by one fantastic piece of
dialogue the baron taunts that almost
every captain has chosen death over
solitude and as he says that we as an
audience already know of one that hasn't
chosen death and as the baron prepares
his final blow brief's tunnel opens up
to save luffy utterly spectacular pacing
execution and dialogue going from a
place of absolute despair to that of
uplifting hope is my absolute favorite
tonal shift in storytelling it
highlights not only a clear contrast but
if done the right way it can also prey
on your anticipation and once we've
experienced that despair the audience as
a whole is ready to be brought back to
hope in this next scene in an almost
catatonic state luffy remains listless
and in shock over the loss of his crew
he's not thankful for being saved he's
simply struggling to process what has
just happened and now it's time for hope
beginning to stir once again luffy
starts to come to his senses there's a
chance brief places the hat on the head
of luffy the captain of the straw hat
pirates and reassures him that he has
something left to fight for that there
is hope but he needs to leave now before
finally saluting him we are now in the
end game emerging from a cloud of dust
like the force of nature the future king
of the pirates should be luffy
effortlessly dodges all of the attacks
of the baron utilizing this newfound
motivation and the tunnels from his
friend he has a second chance at this a
second chance to save his friends his
family the baron has laughed menacingly
in the face of trust friendship and
loyalty but it's that very aspect of
luffy's character that will be the
difference maker in this exchange as
brief helps to distract the baron as
luffy begins sprinting his way towards
the giant
luffy is here to save his friends and
right now brief falls under that
category too enraged by this luffy
breaks one of the arrows in his grip
before firing a massive punch towards
the baron drilling him in the face
meeting his mark and with a reassuring
stare luffy looks back towards brief and
comically makes the salute of the
toothbrush mustache pirates toward him
the old luffy is back it's time to save
everyone filled with purpose and with a
series of ferocious attacks at full
power luffy lands consecutive blow after
blow on this giant plant and as it
begins to come apart the group rejoices
and that's when the little girl says
something is wrong that the voices
aren't coming from that but from
somewhere else
this is the most grotesque scene
in all of one piece bar none and it's
not even close and once again this
doesn't put me off the film in the
slightest i want to make clear the
darker the place this film can take you
the more potential it has i think to
take you out of it and uplift you
revealed to be a scapegoat and not the
main flower the giant illusion revealed
itself to be composed of thousands if
not millions of those deadly arrows of
baron's creation now all pointing toward
luffy the real flower of the hour
reveals itself in all of its horrific
might the sound design for this creature
this parasite that prays in the fear and
loneliness of people has a sound and
moan that accomplished it that honestly
made me feel like a small kid watching
my very first horror film and once this
torturous contorted monster reveals its
true form on the barren shoulder the
blood-red moon overlooking this
spectacle is blotted out by a storm of
arrows falling from the sky towards
luffy meeting their mark and planting
themselves like a traumatizing field of
flowers around the young straw hat
pirate
around this point in the film is when i
felt physically and emotionally
uncomfortable and if you'd believe it
this is the most shocked i've been while
watching an anime film i've seen
harrowing stories depicting horrific
events over the course of my life many
that have left a mark on me but to take
a character so full of hope enthusiasm
and optimism and to throw him into a
situation where he is on the cusp of
death and emotional breakdown has
affected me like few films i've ever
seen whether it's the gaunt distraught
face of luffy his rattling quiet moans
of agony or the crimson palette that
seems to be bathing the entire scene
itself this is horror in its purest form
and i will never forget it resigned to
defeat papa begins to turn tail and run
when his daughter shouts out to luffy
that she can still hear his crew he
still has something to fight for and
once again our brains make a comparison
the once bouncy uplifting carefree
captain now pierced all over his back by
arrows forces him to slowly hobble to
try to do something once again there's
no music in this section it's as if all
life and joy has been sucked out of this
scene all we can hear are the
whimperings from luffy and the rattling
of the arrows jutting out from his back
papa leans down to his daughter and asks
if she's sure because he can't seem to
hear anything it's at this moment the
daughter reveals to him that all the
instances where he's tried to pretend or
to impress them she knew that he was
really scared that he was always trying
to pretend to be a hero for her but then
the little girl says that she always
knew that her dad was really strong and
brave and that she never needed to be
convinced overcome by emotion and a
sudden desire to be the man his daughter
believes him to be papa picks up a bow
one of the arrows in the rocks and takes
aim on the disgusting plant with it
squeals hard it's image imitating and
papa's aim shaky he releases his attack
an action that was made a reality by the
belief his daughter had for him and it
destroys the monstrous plant and in an
instant in what i thought was an
inspired decision all of the baron's
crew suddenly turned to trees all of
this time they have been illusions and
now the illusion is gone the baron is
alone left to stew in the filth of the
floral remnants that gave him the
reality he wanted incensed he turns his
attention to the father
there's an interesting implication right
here with this attack typically at the
very end of these films the straw hats
all win the day the side characters say
their goodbyes and all is well and while
this film does end on an uplifting note
in one respect showing relief wash over
luffy's face before he returns to his
normal giddy self this movie also makes
the interesting choice of implying the
baron is now dead after the punch from
luffy the screen goes black and all we
hear is his monologue lamenting over the
death of his friends until they all
respond to him saying sorry that he's
been left alone for so long as if to
imply that he's met them or reconnected
in the afterlife and while this isn't
something we've come to expect from
luffy or even wimpies in general i'm not
exactly sure what sort of future or
alternative there was for a fully
fleshed out and complex character like
the baron to have this is a film that
isn't afraid to show people at their
absolute worst and the ending to this
like many great films is one that i
could see being discussed and argued
over for quite some time but what do i
think about this film now that all is
said and done well put quite simply it
is now one of my favorite films i've
ever seen in my life it invokes laughter
tears hope despair and relief all in the
span of an hour and a half one important
thing to take into consideration however
is it's as effective as it is because of
the manga and the story associated with
it carrying all the heavy lifting in
understanding the characters of the
straw hat crew but what this movie does
with them is truly something to behold
and one i will be sure to come back to
for many
many years to come an absolute
marvel of a film
okay that was sufficiently heavy time to
move on to something a little more
lighthearted next up one piece mega
mecha soldier of karakuri castle
[Music]
this video is brought to you by
ridge.com tnm most people are still
using wallets designed in the 1990s and
in this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated and i should know i've been
using the same wallet since i was 15
years old and that means i've been using
some outdated wallet for the last 14
years of my life in the same way phones
have gotten more practical and compact
over the last few decades so too have
wallets and it's honestly made a massive
difference to my pockets personally i
hate having cumbersome items in there
and this totally fits my new lifestyle
it holds up to 12 separate cards plus
room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from and if that wasn't enough to
win you over yet check out their 30 000
5 star reviews the durable nature of
each of these wallets comes with a
lifetime warranty so in theory you could
buy this one wallet and carry it for
life and the rich team have told me that
they're so confident that you like it
that they'll actually let you test drive
it for 45 days that means you can send
it back for a full refund if it's not up
to your own standards right now there's
a special offer going where you can get
10 off with free worldwide shipping and
returns and you can get all of this by
going to ridge.com tnm and using the
coupon code tnm link is in the
description
one piece mega mecha soldier of karakuri
castle is a 2006 film produced and
distributed yeah okay i think you get it
by now it's all done by toy animation
the opening to this one is actually
quite captivating possibly for more than
one reason the breasts i mean best part
of this opening is that it utilizes the
film technique known as the mystery box
the straw hats have found a treasure
chest and they expect vast amounts of
wealth to lie within but they get
something completely different and oh by
the way the merry is floating away with
no one on board and their current boat
is on fire this albeit small bit of
tension made for a fun opening that
certainly held my attention within the
first seven minutes of the story we've
been introduced the lady in the treasure
chest have established the overall goal
and next destination a means of getting
there and have seen nami's chest
continue to jiggle in really forced and
strange ways i wonder if this is a sign
of things to come wink wink anyways the
title card drops as they make their way
towards the old ladies island in search
of this golden crown she's told them
about and this is essentially how we're
all introduced to the rest of the main
cast we'll be dealing with on the island
with the seemingly misleading name of
mecca island it seems the island home of
the old lady is hostile towards pirates
and as soon as they reclaim her they
begin operating their defensive systems
against the straw hat pirates offering
up some nice opportunities for the
machines sent to destroy the ship for
zoro to defend it and for nami's chest
to continue to defy physics even though
the ship was damaged the island's
defenses and the songs that were sung as
they approached have filled them with
more motivation to find its mysterious
treasure and this is when i begin taking
issue with this film obviously almost
every film has some level of contrivance
and these convenient happenings are here
more often than not to help move the
plot forward and i can appreciate that
however when i notice these conveniences
it really takes me out of the story
being told it ruins my immersion you see
in this scene the crew are struggling to
decipher the riddle in the sun however
when luffy solves it it's revealed that
the answer could have only been observed
from the sea in the exact position they
are currently floating i guess they're
super lucky then okay
it's revealed that the inhabitants of
the island have gotten as far as they
have with the riddle however in a matter
of moments the crew discover once again
by pure chance the rest of the riddle as
luffy punches the snakehead revealing a
cave because of this ratchet the lord of
the island figures it a good idea to
utilize them to solve the rest of the
mystery also robert and nami wear these
outfits despite no one else on the crew
changing their clothes when they left
why did they change their clothes luffy
agrees to ratchet's terms and so they
all begin making their way towards the
mouth of the snake i honestly enjoyed
this section there's a fun bit of
tension and some great teamwork on
display from the straw hats as they
navigate the treacherous passageways
into it naturally as has been the trend
with the mystery thus far drumroll
please now luffy once again solves the
next few steps in and admittedly i'll be
a convenient fashion though once it's
uncovered that the island is a giant
turtle yes you heard me a giant turtle
ratchet reveals that he has no use left
for the pirates anymore as he wants to
rule the world of course with the giant
turtle
of course i don't think this is a
particularly great implementation of a
world ending conquering strategy but who
am i to say it's not plus the movie's
almost over and i do not want to delay
this monstrosity any further as i said
this is the final section of the film
and it's pretty straightforward and by
the books a weapon
to surpass metal gear now that ratchet
has what he needs luffy and the gang
need to stop him before it's too late
all the while dealing with his followers
and traps along the way it's a typical
raid the castle type scenario there's
some decent action and some cool set
pieces with zoro sanji and robin whose
know-how and powers are used to create
an effect a couple of times in the story
which i appreciate but taking center
stage in this conflict of course between
ratchet in a giant robot suit is luffy
as the main event of the film it
receives the most screen time although
personally i found it to be my least
favorite fight in the film itself i
think this in part had a lot to do with
the fact that i didn't like or even
connect with the character of ratchet on
a single level
very much like most of these one-piece
films ratchet is a one-dimensional
one-note character that is there to
serve a single purpose before fading
into our subconscious never to be
thought of again and really these are
the biggest weaknesses of these films
for me aside from movie six and perhaps
movie four the antagonists don't seem to
capture my interest at all and that's a
shame because a lot of these films do a
great job in creating natural and
lovable interactions between the various
straw hats
they harden in response to physical
trauma with that said luffy wins while
doing the rubber man hokey pokey and i
get to move on to the modern one-piece
films overall i'd say this one is a real
middle of the road type story it's not
terrible but it's definitely not great i
can't say i'll be returning to this one
but i don't have bad memories from it
either well except for
next up one piece strong world this is
by far the longest one piece film i've
reviewed to date with a runtime of
113 minutes despite being almost two
hours long the pacing in this one is
actually remarkably good the first 30
minutes largely concern itself with
introducing us to the new antagonist of
the picture as well as the straw head
crew however what adds interest to the
first 30 minutes is how it's structured
beginning in a set of confusing
circumstances as the crew are split up
finding themselves dealing with an
assortment of intimidating and fierce
beasts amidst the floating rocks in the
sky before showing us how they in fact
got into the situation they find
themselves in this is interesting into
and of itself but what adds a ton of
flavor and interest to this film for me
is its writer and its antagonist this is
the first film in the one piece
cinematic universe that was penned by
achiera oda and while i thought some of
the prior films did a fantastic job at
capturing the heart of one piece none
can achieve that same feeling one piece
can offer if it's not outlined by the
walking one piece encyclopedia himself
mr oda but i think what makes one piece
for me so enthralling is how it always
feels like a massive sprawling story
that's interconnected with thousands of
other chapters and while as i said the
other films achieved great heights none
of them could claim to be part of the
greater story unlike this film
additionally what i found interesting
about this particular piece of film was
that it comes with additional required
watching before you actually watch it in
the form of one piece episode zero or
chapter zero if you wish to read it a 15
minute long flashback sequence detailing
the history and lore behind the main
antagonist of this story shiki having
come into conflict with roger and having
lost he can't believe it when roger in
fact gets taken in and placed on the
execution block by the navy not one to
take this information well thinking how
on earth the weaklings of the navy could
possibly apprehend such a formidable
captain in roger he takes it upon
himself to take on sengoku and garp at
once destroying half of naval hq he gets
taken to impel down but once he's ready
slices off his own legs to free himself
and escape the facility not to be seen
for another 20 years around the same
time this film takes place and really
this is another trend oda has managed to
end also shiki isn't a one note
character he has a backstory with needs
desires ego and shame that coupled with
his quirky fun personality and crew and
we have the makings of an entertaining
foil for luffy to bounce off of or at
least he will but for now after nami
demonstrated her fantastic navigation
and forecasting skills she gets stolen
from the straw hats by shiki before the
rest of them get cast off into random
parts of a floating archipelago now
isolated or in various groups the straw
hats need to reconnect and save their
crewmate nami and to be honest they most
certainly do regroup and much faster
than i anticipated which really helped
the pacing though it did make me wonder
how and why is the story progressing
this way well it's all in the service of
the best midpoint swerve of all the
movies i've seen while i adore what
movie 6 did with its swerve i feel like
this one in strong world felt distinctly
more one piece and offered a lot in the
way of future setup moving into the
final act and it delivers this midpoint
in a really fun creative and powerful
way to get to this point the prior goal
of finding and regrouping with nami
takes an unexpected swerve with the help
of a giant bird with electrical powers
instead of being rescued nami takes the
initiative and escapes successfully
meeting up with luffy at first but later
zoro sanji usof and chopper 2. we see
all of these characters regroup at
different moments but the funniest for
me came after all the heartfelt smiles
and excitement
i found unreasonably funny i really
enjoyed the angle that this film takes
in establishing its stakes shiki is
targeting the east blue where most of
the crew is from and what's more is
shiki is gonna put on a demonstration
today with the only village in the
floating archipelago he's created and he
intends to level it and who's standing
there to defend it nami and the rest of
the east blue wall chopper didn't come
from the east blue luffy zoro sanji nami
and usop all are from there and they're
all there to defend against this massive
force in shiki the sun piercing through
the horizon creates a gorgeous hue that
bathes the entire fight sequence this is
one of the only times in one piece where
we see a large portion of the straw hats
all focus on one character
however
despite
he is impossibly powerful and at this
point in the series possibly the
strongest they've ever faced this is one
of the last remnants from roger's era of
piracy and he's after taking out all of
the strongest fighters from the straw
hat pirates with little to no effort
from a defiant stand against shiki to
being unconscious and trapped within a
rock pillar leaving nami alone to
bargain for their lives however before
she leaves and becomes sheiki's
companion and navigator he offers her
the chance to leave a farewell message
for her crew and it's this aspect of
shiki's character that once again adds a
three-dimensionality to him in this
scene he felt as shockingly imposing as
he did because he brought more to the
table than simply an evil and brooding
persona throughout this film he's been
reasonable shown to have a sense of
humor and even sometimes has been
downright silly and when you go from
silly and lightheaded to dominant and
uncompromising that's when the audience
feels it the most the audience more than
anything else in a story resonates when
it feels contrast had he been a person
that was brooding with confidence and
always trying to appear powerful if he
were to eventually demonstrate that
power he wouldn't be nearly as
impressive because the viewer was
prepared for it sort of bracing
themselves and the very fact that is not
how he is written is the core reason
behind why he is at least for me so
effective as an antagonistic force in
this story creating what will be a
terrific motivator in a farewell message
nami leaves behind which will inform and
inspire the remaining half of this story
and seeing as this film is almost two
hours long instead of cramming it into
the end of this video i'm gonna cover
the second half of this film in next
week's video alongside film z film gold
and stampede i hope to see you there but
for now that'll do it for this video
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week and thank you all so much
for watching
[Music]